[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben heute gibt es wieder
eine neue folge aus der reihe wie vom
bäcker ich meine verschiedene sachen die
so schmecken wie vom bäcker dazu gibt es
auch eine ganze playlist die verlinke
ich euch gerne und heute gibt es
streusel taler mit pudding füllung so
lecker ich starte jetzt direkt mit dem
hefeteig und schreibe ich die ganz
genauen mengenangaben unten in die
infobox ich gebe jetzt mein mehl in eine
ausreichend große schüssel um es genau
zu nehmen nämlich meine rührschüssel von
der küchenmaschine ihr könnt es aber
auch mit der hand werk neben gebt nicht
alles vom mail hinein last ein teil
beiseite denn es kommt gleich mit gefühl
und da werde ich jetzt eine mulde bilden
gibt dann lauf warme milch rhein ein
teelöffel vom zucker und frische hefe
und dann könnt ihr das verrühren und
erst mal fünf minuten zugedeckt ein
bisschen arbeiten lassen
[Musik]
jetzt konnte die hefe schon mal
vorarbeiten ich öffne den deckel und
gibt jetzt die restlichen zutaten dazu
also einmal den restlichen zucker mit
rein dann gebe ich zerlassener butter 1
ei und noch eine prise salz dazu dann
könnt ihr so nach und nach mit dem mehl
arbeiten dass sie das stück für stück
dazu gibt und das ganze zu einem
geschmeidigen hefe teig verknetet
[Musik]
ich habe jetzt auch nicht alles von
meinem mehr verbraucht also gute 50
gramm sind noch übrig geblieben das
kommt wirklich immer auf die größe des
ice an und daher immer schön langsam ein
arbeiten meint eick ist jetzt schön
geschmeidig aber auch fest den habe ich
jetzt auf der arbeitsfläche noch mal ein
paar minuten geknetet und gebe jetzt
zurück in die schüssel und damit er
gleich auch nicht an klebt gerne so ein
bisschen fett in form von back
transpower oder öl noch sind dazugeben
und verschließen und jetzt muss er 30
minuten dann gehen
[Musik]
so ich mache jetzt in der zwischenzeit
weiter mit der pudding füllung und dafür
kochen uns an einfachen pudding ob wir
können natürlich auch eine fertige
pudding mischung dem aus der tüte ich
zeige euch wie es ganz einfach ohne tüte
funktioniert dafür habe ich hier eine
kleine schüssel da gebe ich schon mal
einen teil von der milch rein also
grasser 150 milliliter ungefähr die
anderen drei halten milliliter kommen
dann gleich direkt in den top teams
einfach meine augen macht dann gebe ich
da ein eigelb dazu das ist jetzt nicht
nur für die farbe sondern auch für die
konsistenz und hinzu kommt dann noch
speisestärke und das verrückte dann
glatt und geben dann die restliche milch
in den topf
jetzt kommt wie gesagt die restliche
milch einmal in den topf dazu kommt dann
auch noch zucker und natürlich vanille
extrakt und ich werde das ganze dann
einmal erhitzen das muss nicht unbedingt
hoch steigen aber es sollte schon
erwärmt werden so dass sich bläschen
bilden das seht ihr dann an der
oberfläche und dann kommt die eigelb
mischung dazu und wird unter ständigem
rühren einmal aufgekocht und eingedeckt
zu
[Musik]
dem pudding habe ich jetzt auch mal
ungefüllt und direkt auf die oberfläche
frischhaltefolie gegeben damit sich auch
keine haut bildet es soll ja menschen
geben die mögen diese haut ich
persönlich nicht ihr könnt aber in die
kommentare schreiben ich werde jetzt in
der zwischenzeit während der pudding
abkühlt einmal sahne steif schlagen das
funktioniert am besten wenn die sahne
ganz kalt und frisch aus dem kühlschrank
kommen es gibt ja gleich auch noch ein
bisschen sahne fester zu tag das steif
und werde es dann anschließend gleich
nochmal zum pudding geben
[Musik]
die sache ist jetzt schon steif ich habe
jetzt hier den abgekühlten coding ich
hab's vorher vorbereitet es sind geht so
schnell bei mir und den pudding gebe ich
jetzt in eine ausreichend große schüssel
dann nehme ich jetzt auch wieder ein
handrührgerät
ich hab jetzt auch die aufsätze nicht
gewaschen den schritt spare ich mir
einfach und jetzt so ungefähr 30
sekunden noch mal mixen auflockern und
dann mit einem teig schaber die sahne
unterheben
[Musik]
jetzt machen wir unseren letzten
bestandteil nämlich die leckeren
streusel dafür gebe ich alle zutaten
einfach in eine große schüssel und
verwende meine sauberen hände und werde
dir einfach zusammen kneten bei der
butter könnte darauf achten dass die
schön kalt ich habe sie auch insofern
stückchen geschnitten und dann wie
gesagt einfach alle zutaten reingeben
und verkneten
[Musik]
der hefeteig ist richtig gut aufgegangen
ich nehme jetzt schon mal raus und die
dürfte ihnen auch noch mal so ganz grob
kneten teilt ihnen dann entweder in 67
oder in acht thaler jetzt kommen dann
immer ganz darauf an wie groß ihr sie
haben möchte ich glaube ich mache
größere thaler und werde dann durch
sechs teilen
[Musik]
die teiglinge habe ich jetzt so kugeln
geformt und noch mal zehn minuten und
ruhen lassen so konnten sie noch mal ein
bisschen aufgehen und sind nicht ganz so
elastisch wenn ich sie jetzt aus rolle
das ausräumen macht dir ganz einfach mit
einem aus rolf starb so ungefähr
zentimeter dick und schön rund
[Musik]
ich habe das ganze jetzt aufgeteilt auf
zwei backbleche jeweils vier teiglinge
auf einem blech weil die werden noch
ordentlich aufgehen und jetzt werden sie
mit milch bestrichen einfach mit einem
pinsel und dann können auch die streusel
daran haften bleiben und dann kommen sie
in den vorgeheizten backofen bei 180
grad ober und unterhitze ich würde mal
sagen für zirka 20 minuten aber schaut
dass sie nicht so dunkel werden
[Musik]
nach dem backen dann die streusel thaler
schon einmal halbieren also einmal
aufschneiden danach müssten sie
vollständig auskühlen ihr könnt doch
erst auskühlen lassen und dann halbieren
ich habe jetzt auch meine creme schon
mal hier in meinen spritzbeutel gefüllt
vorne habe ich eine rosenblüte dran die
300 ist das verlinkte ich euch in der
infobox und jetzt wird einfach gefüllt
und ich habe mir überlegt ganz spontan
noch frische früchte reinzumachen ich
habe jetzt zum beispiel
johannisbeeren da genau johannisbeeren
habe ich ihr könnt auch frische
himbeeren nehmen erst an was auch immer
gab saison hat
[Musik]
jetzt kommt der test ist ich bin
gespannt was du sagst als haben sie
gerade rein kam so
überraschend
und mitten im dreh also wann kommt der
täter ist ich würde euch raten mit
messer und gabel zu essen habe ich das
ja auch die creme da drin haben nigel
clough
augusta
umschluss sich genau und innen soft
große trainieren muss merck land da drin
ist ein vanillepudding den ich noch mit
auf geschlagener sahne verfeinert aber
ich gebe zu
ich würde jetzt
beweist
[Musik]
jetzt bin ich gespannt haben machen wir
direkt punktevergabe bord von 10 10 von
in hama lecker ich finde es noch besser
als das thema so hart so richtig hat der
ist richtig richtig
das ist aber wohl doch mehr wir
schreiben möchte immer die genauen
nährwerte auch unten in den po box check
der wind war mario bauer stück und da
ist nicht nur noch johannisbeeren ihr
könnt ja auch früchte ihr könnt früchte
nehmen möchte der könnte aber auch
weglassen 2 kommen euch überlassen ich
habe übrigens am ende noch puderzucker
darauf gegeben jetzt nicht mein
geschmack sondern einfach weil es schick
aussieht die streusel schmecken frisch
intensiv nichts sondern wirklich richtig
ich finde aber auch diese ganze
komponente streubel flieger hier ist
wirklich sehr schlüssig der hefe das ist
nicht normal fan und dieser vanillecreme
unbedingt nachmachen kann uns jetzt mehr
wenn man also ein 2 1 gemacht hat war
ich mal für sich aufnehmen muss sondern
ja und jetzt bestimmt
aber wir lassen dich gleich ausprobiert
[Musik]
also ganz viel freude beim nachmachen
kommt zurück zum video und hinterlasst
mit einer feedback sehr gerne und
ansonsten hinterlasst dem kanal
natürlich ein kostenloses abo wenn ihr
das nicht getan habt also bis zunächst
mal tschüss
[Gelächter]
[Musik]